what if midlife is not a crisis what if
it's a chrysalis what I've tried to do
in the last few years is to really focus
on a pro-aging message we are growing
our whole lives it's just we're moving
from the playing field of the body to
the playing field of the
soul today the founder of the modern
Elder Academy chip connley returns to
the podcast to continue our conversation
about reframing aging when I was younger
I might have been thinking like okay I
got to show off and I think as you get
older you start getting focused on not
showing off but showing up we talk about
the importance of having a growth
mindset something called age fluidity a
person who's age fluid is somebody who's
not defined by their age or by their
generation they see age as almost like a
costume that you either Dawn or shed I
just love this man his wisdom truly is a
gift so without further Ado please
enjoy